economía en france 24 está conmigo en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela buenas
noches bienvenida comenzamos hablando de
la ocde que revisó sus proyecciones
económicas para el 2020 y el 2021
santiago buenas noches hablamos de la
organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo económico que calcula que la
economía mundial sufrirá este año una
caída del 4,2 por ciento esto es un poco
más alto de lo que se estimaba hace dos
meses y medio es decir estar reduciendo
como esa perspectiva pero empeora cuando
hablamos de quien 2021 que cree que la
recuperación será más lenta la situación
en algunos países de américa latina es
la siguiente santiago el país más
afectado este año será argentina que
prolongaría los tres años que ya lleva
en recesión y se contraería en un 12,9
por ciento méxico podría contraerse 92
por ciento en 2020 y colombia vería caer
su economía en 83 en brasil en chile el
impacto será un poco menor con una caída
1 del 6% escuchemos
por igual a primera vista nuestra
proyección con crecimiento del pib
mundial en un sufrir 21 del 4.2 por
ciento parece mismos pero aún dejaría
casi todas las economías de las más
frágiles a finales de 2021 de lo que
eran al terminar el 29
ya veíamos cifras de proyección de la
economía de méxico pero hoy coincide que
se cumplen dos años de la llegada al
poder del presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador cuál es el balance económico
entonces en el país santiago los dos
años del presidente mexicano se cumplen
en medio de lo que será una grave crisis
económica prevista para este año como ya
lo veíamos en 2018 la economía ya venía
débil un aumento del 22 por ciento pero
en 2019 se contrajo es decir que la
crisis venía desde mucho antes de la
pandemia del coronavirus con el nuevo
panorama el segundo
de la región que más caída presenta para
este año es méxico después de argentina
se estima que en 2020 habrá 2 millones
de pobres más en este país en términos
de empleo
andrés manuel lópez obrador es recibió
un país con una tasa de desocupación del
3,4 por ciento que es relativamente baja
santiago si se compara con otras grandes
economías de la región y ya para este
año están alrededor del 5 por ciento
pero el verdadero problema laboral de
méxico está como ya sabemos en la
informalidad que afecta a más de la
mitad de la población ocupada los planes
gubernamentales en los últimos dos años
se han caracterizado por un severo plan
de austeridad gubernamental que incluyó
la polémica supresión de recursos para
ciencia desastres y derechos humanos
hablemos ahora de argentina y perú
porque así los empleados del agro están
exigiendo mejores condiciones en su vida
laboral
santiago por un lado una huelga de
trabajadores del sector agroindustrial
afecta a este martes la actividad de
puertos y plantas de molienda
que es uno de los mayores productores y
exportadores mundiales de granos y
derivados el cese de actividades fue
declarado tras el fracaso de las
negociaciones con la representación
patronal que lleva varios meses el
gobierno ya había dictado una
conciliación obligatoria pero no han
llegado a un acuerdo lo que reclaman es
un aumento salarial y mejoras en las
condiciones laborales lo mismo pasa en
el sur de perú en la región de ica en
donde se producen productos como
arándanos espárragos o alcachofas
cientos de agricultores bloquearon la
vía panamericana que es la más grande
del país y que atraviesa todo el sur del
continente con estas mismas exigencias
hablemos ahora de los indicadores como
el sfa los principales parques del mundo
santiago bolsa y desarrollo de nuevo en
máximos históricos en dos de sus
principales indicadores nasdaq y
standard and poor's ayudó a que
retornaron las negociaciones de estímulo
en el congreso las bolsas europeas en
siguen subiendo por los avances en la
vacuna anti cover y en américa latina
las bolsas presentaron fuertes ganancias
después
de pérdidas anteriores y la cifra del
día para el cierre sorprende 34 mil 800
millones de dólares santiago eso es la
capitalización de mercado a la que
apunta el bien vi después de su oferta
inicial de acciones en la bolsa de nueva
york que se llevará a cabo en los
próximos días en total van a salir a la
venta acciones a entre 40 y 450 horas
gracias daniela por esta actualización
del mundo económico es todo por el
momento aquí en france24 siga con
nuestra programación feliz noche
[Música]